a
más de un centenar de personas se
manifestaron el 22 de octubre ante la
estación de policía de un tuba tuba
estos activistas medioambientales le
rendían homenaje a su colega fitur y
asesinada hace un año
aquiles se había opuesto firmemente a la
construcción de una nueva mina de carbón
en la zona sus colegas están convencidos
de que el asesinato está relacionado con
su lucha pero la investigación no avanza
decimos que la policía no se está
tomando el caso en serio queremos que el
comisario sepa que los asesinos siguen
ahí afuera y van a matar a más
activistas los miembros de esta ong que
se opone sistemáticamente a la
construcción de nuevas centrales
eléctricas de carbón están bajo
constante amenaza
recibimos bastantes mensajes de textos
amenazándonos de muerte la seguridad no
es nada buena algunos de nosotros nos
estamos quedando en un lugar seguro para
protegernos y en este momento también
tenemos guardaespaldas privados private
cats
no hay quien detenga a estos jóvenes que
no quieren que haya minas de carbón la
hija de peak y le explica que les
ofrecieron dinero y una nueva casa para
convencer a la comunidad de que
abandonara la zona pero se negaron
estaba aquí esa noche estaba cortando
cebollas para preparar la cena eran
alrededor de las 7 de la noche y su
cuerpo estaba aquí encontramos su cuerpo
tirado aquí esa es la séptima bala la
mayoría de la gente de esta comunidad no
tienen mucha educación creo que lo que
la puso en peligro fue su intento de
educar a la gente de concienciarlos de
sus derechos ella sólo estaba tratando
de hacer el bien los sudafricanos se
oponen al carbón que proporcionan más
del 80 por ciento de la energía del país
porque el carbón significa contaminación
las 15 centrales eléctricas de sudáfrica
emiten más dióxido de azufre que china y
eeuu juntos combatí es una de las
primeras centrales eléctricas de carbón
del país se construyó en los años 50 sus
instalaciones son obsoletas que este año
no pudo ser clausurada como estaba
previsto por la falta de electricidad en
el país para el director de escom la
empresa nacional de electricidad
sudáfrica está rezagada en su transición
energética
no habíamos trabajado tanto en esto como
lo estamos haciendo ahora siempre sonaba
como si todavía hubiera tiempo
todavía hay otros cinco años o el
periodo que sea lamentablemente el
tiempo se nos pasó muy rápido y debemos
ponernos al día no hay excusa deberíamos
haber avanzado mucho más
pretoria ahora parece apostarle a las
energías renovables en esta central
estatal por ejemplo se está llevando a
cabo un proyecto de reconversión muy
original la central eléctrica de carbón
será transformada en un parque solar
esto es lo que le explicó el director a
una delegación ministerial francesa que
visitó como a ti no sólo aplica no es lo
más difícil de esta reconversión no es
encontrar socios sino evitar la pérdida
de empleos se van a perder empleos
debido a los paneles que se ven ahí
fuera
algunos son controlados remotamente
otros son de auto mantenimiento y la
gente de aquí no está tan capacitada
solo tienen habilidades funcionales
como se puede hacer que acepten en esta
tecnología
la industria del carbón emplea más de
100.000 trabajadores
proporciona el sustento a más de un
millón de personas varios países entre
ellos francia han prometido aportar 8500
millones de dólares en cinco años para
financiar la transición energética
sudafricana para la ministra francesa de
transición ecológica una iniciativa como
la de combatir es un ejemplo
si no damos esperanzas sobre esta
transición ecológica si damos la
sensación de que solo vamos a cerrar las
centrales si no hablamos del futuro no
conseguiremos que todos nos apoyen esta
transición ecológica debe ser también
una oportunidad para crear el nuevo
mundo siempre eso me gusta lo que se
propone así recordar que estamos
orgullosos de nuestro pasado estamos
orgullosos de haber desarrollado el país
produciendo energía pero que ahora nos
proyectamos hacia el futuro puede ser
que el compromiso de pretoria con las
energías renovables haya llegado tarde
pero es impresionante
sudáfrica es el mayor productor de
energía solar de áfrica por delante de
egipto y argelia en los últimos años los
parques solares han surgido como hongos
en el norte del país cada vez son más
los operadores privados que aprovechan
los excepcionales niveles de radiación
solar este proyecto por ejemplo en el
norte de la ciudad de curumaní se
construyó en menos de seis meses el
concepto es único le vende su
electricidad a un cliente situado a más
de mil kilómetros al sur del centro de
producción el empresario que está detrás
del proyecto dice que nada de esto
habría sido posible sin los cambios
legislativos
los últimos meses los productores
independientes ahora pueden venderle su
electricidad directamente al sector
privado
lo que ha cambiado la normativa es que
ha hecho que todos los proyectos de
hasta 100 megavatios estén exentos de
requerir una licencia para generar
eso significa que el proceso para poner
los proyectos en marcha es mucho más
fácil
los clientes empiezan a tener la
posibilidad de elegir a quién le compran
la electricidad no sólo puede proceder
del municipio o de escom sino de otras
entidades privadas que podría ser más
barata más limpia y más sostenible de lo
que hay ahora aunque sudáfrica depende
en gran medida del carbón tiene previsto
que para 2030 el 25 por ciento de su
electricidad proceda de energías
renovables el objetivo es tener cero
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
para el año 2050